je m'appelle sa malcom sourit je suis
journaliste et j'ai pris le risque il ya
six mois d'un filtre et les mosquée
clandestine de la banlieue parisienne
il se doute de rien impossible du compte
arrêter quand tu veux tu fais quoi vous
partirez avec kuyt n'inquiète pas c'est
bientôt fini là pour mission de créer
une cellule d'al-qaïda rasé vos barbe
fondé vous dans la masse fumait buvait
des fondé l'amérique et israël s'il le
faut mais personne doit se doter de rien
je te suis vous savez que maintenant
vous êtes complices je peux vous
garantir qu'on prison quand les barbus
seront vous avez trahis ils vont pas
vous raté alors vous allez continuer
c'est à dire que j'ai pas deux fois
pourquoi est-ce que je tiens à te battre
la vengeance n'a rien à voir avec
l'islam qu'est ce que tu penses de sol
qu'est ce qui te dit
commencent à utiliser les autres ça veut
dire quoi
bien sûr qu'il est complètement parano
j'arrête pas de vous le dire
il rentre elle était couvert de sang tu
vois ce qui se passe sinon je dis que je
vais fouiller dans ses affaires
je tairai me santi je te fais plus
confiance teaser tel est le programme de
laisser tranquille la situation a changé
les calanques est ok j'arrête
j'ai toujours trouvé que d'un exemple
une vague d'attentats a secoué toute la
france de traction sera la première
d'une brasserie champs elysées à une
heure de grande affluence
c'est un grand honneur
on fuit situe dix ans on en guerre et
dans toute guerre il ya des victimes
parce que tu crois que la volonté d'en
bas situé des enfants